[Musique]
magicien rebonjour majeurs seront
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle thinker view on voudrait avoir
vos impressions votre senti vos
recherches tout sur votre dernier livre
sur votre expérience dans le monde
d'internet le monde des hackers tout ça
alors mal ici rock c'est votre à quatre
roues saônoise quel est votre vrai
prénom
raïna raï n'a pas tu veux avec l'accent
qui va bien
il faut pas que ça commence à
pourquoi ce livre
d'une part parce que on me l'a commandé
mais c'était pas la vraie raison en fait
c'est parce que
je sentais aussi bien que d'autres
personnes qu'il manquait un travail de
synthèse
qui en regroupe justement qui met en
correspondance qui mais de manière
accessible
des connaissances on va dire c'est
sophistiqué sur des sujets très actuels
à un niveau suffisamment accessible pour
la sempiternelle madame michu qui
n'existe pas mais quand même pour un
public très large qui ne l'est pas qui
ne fait pas partie du groupe des
sachants de la technique qu'on connaît
pas mal tu l'aidés c'est qu'il est
sachant de l'internet qui laissa
changements techniques au bo fois tu
vois tous les gars parce qu'il ya
essentiellement des gars qui ont essayé
de me faire le coup à temps toute façon
je vais lire ton truc et je vais te
remonter toutes les erreurs et j'attends
encore
qu'est ce que on va se tutoyer parce que
sinon c'est cramé
qu'est ce que tu peux me dire des
communautés de hackers qu'est ce que
t'en connais
allez tu veux que je boxe du monde celle
d'autres personnes
à bord c'est autre chose que tu m'as
promis non pardon façon
alors les communautés
les communautés on va voter oui bah
c'est super règle en fait les
communautés en france les communautés
ailleurs ce que en fait j'ai
essentiellement parlé d'un anonyme
housse mais vous animaux ça
veut tout et rien dire ouais c'est ça en
fait j'ai essayé si tu veux d'expliquer
un peu la gêne et généalogie en fait 2
pourquoi aujourd'hui certaines personnes
qu'on un temps relativement souvent de
manière
c'est vocales
sont en fait
une relation assez intime assez assez
qu'en accord avec un internet d'où ça
vient en fait les hacker au sens très
large sont là les gens qui pour beaucoup
font ont fait sonné avec où sont nés
deux lacs de tous cas en fait s'est
développé avec internet tu parles des
piliers de munich
non enfin tu parles de bière ou
d'oktoberfest
communiqué non
on reviendra ça venez venez sur nos
réseaux on vous expliquera
est ce que tu sens que les différentes
communautés comme la communauté de la
sécu la sécu ou de la communauté des
activistes sont en train de converger et
de se politiser
ça a déjà été fait en fait ça s'est déjà
fait hier des années et c'est un peu ce
que j'ai essayé d'introduire justement
avec anonymous parce que on a quand même
vu cette politisation des geeks au sens
très large avec notamment
les premières les premiers cas de
lancement d' alerte que ce soit les
débuts de wikileaks
les débuts médiatiques on va dire de
wikileaks donc 2000 2009 2010 et après
avec les révolutions arabes et
l'implication toujours croissante de du
collectif anonymous a aussi protéiforme
que ce soit avec avec d'autres
communautés plus petites où on va dire -
moins connus du très grand public tels
que telecomix externe pratiquement oui
enfin pour beaucoup river et là il ya eu
une vraie
il ya eu une vraie et très croissante
qui persiste toujours d'une certaine
manière politisation des geeks où on a
en fait commencé à utiliser des outils
numériques à je parle pas de leur
légalité 1
on a commencé à utiliser le numérique
pour promouvoir pour
promouvoir des idées des idées
politiques pour faire passer des
messages politiques qu'elles portent
vaincre que les messages portent loin ou
pas voilà parce que les services de
renseignement ont cherché à
instrumentaliser ou à prendre le
contrôle de l'idéologie anonymous
on va dire bon il ya eu je pense que les
gens les plus reconnus sa fin les gens
les plus âgés on va dire ça comme ça
sans jugement de valeur ou en
général est générale ouais ouais voilà
un on se comprend sans faire des
générations on sait en fait qu'en france
il ya eu un entrisme très fort de la
part des services dans les années jeu +
90 lorsqu'il lorsque certains ont essayé
de lancer un équivalent français lowe's
du ccc du de caisse computer club
après
qu'on a vu et ce que je raconte un peu
avec
lulzsec c'est qu'il ya eu des
informateurs en termes qui ont été
suffisamment
bien outillé est suffisamment habile
pour
parvenir en fait à
part enseigner les services et les
forces de l'ordre sur les activités des
groupes et des collectifs je crois qu'en
france a moins eu de
yaya moins d'histoire récente comme ça
après voilà 10 pence à bout ça voilà on
n'a pas de tabou qui fait du sabotage
mais
mais enfin après je préviens enfin
pendant les révolutions arabes je
n'étais pas en france tout et où j'étais
un petit nisy donc du coup junior au sud
où il fallait là où nécessité fait loi
je ne pourrai mieux le dire tu
travailles et riz pour la france tu
travaillais comme honorables
contributeurs pour un autre pays pour
requins paix pour le pays d'internet
voilà et pour désengager pour les gens
qui avaient besoin sur le terrain
comme notamment pour désengager en fait
c'était l'économique ce kit envoyé là
bas non mais on s'est parlé d'une
manière
d'une manière assez drôle 56 kg c'est
sacré par fax et du coup ce que très
drôle parce qu'il ya
la relecture du bestiau là
bref c'est une autre histoire et un
copain justement quitté un des visages
de la révolution égyptienne était à la
maison et quand je faisais là la
relecture finale du livre et du coup on
est sorti
boire des bières et du coup je les
présente et
des gens qui étaient anciennement
affecté les comics et du coup c'était la
première fois il se voyait en vrai
c'était assez c'est assez rigolo cool
août à manhattan
mais il avait réalisé qui a brillé
qu'est ce que tu penses de thor
beaucoup de choses rien de particulier
je ne la gêne et ça le fait que à la
base c'était un projet
de la navy américaine
bah c'était un projet de la navy
américaine points enfin depuis ça a
vachement évolué il ya d'autres
problèmes si tu veux que les origines
d'un truc il ya ce qu'on en fait
aujourd'hui il ya un proverbe qui
dit un doute mais le pack doute mais
c'est enfin mon propos ce tu veux si il
y à une privatisation croissante de
beaucoup d'activités
société civile au sens large
qui est faite juste parce que les
bailleurs de fonds
quand il quand il reçoit une grande 1
quand tu reçois canton projets financés
ça vient avec les américains ou les
anglo-saxons appellent saoudite strings
attached ça veut dire ça vient avec des
conditions de dépenses tu as déjà un
budget prévisionnel mais après il ya des
choses que tu ne peux pas faire
parce que tu es payé par intel dans le
cadre de ce projet là il ya des choses
que tu peux pas dire des choses que tu
peux pas faire comme quoi ça dépendra
des conditions de
du bailleur de fonds en question il y
avait sur des projets sur un projet que
j'avais fait
une zone de guerre civile il y avait
à ben ouais t'es sur think you've got
[Musique]
next voilà
en afrique
c'est vrai que ça en forme pas beaucoup
étant donné la situation du continent
mais passons mais il si tu veux la le
financement en très grande partie en
majeure partie était par mon
gouvernement européens et basse c'était
pas vraiment possible de critiquer là
l'implication de ce pays-là et de sa
politique étrangère dans le pays
c'est comme ça donc divorce et bien non
oui oui oui mais c'était pas côte
d'ivoire pour revenir ni guerre civile
oui pour en revenir à tort mais tu sais
que j'ai des copains un peu partout
qu'on a des copains un peu partout on en
connaît on a la fièvre
on est certain jean est certain qu'ils
ne me dire bon tort
quand on dévoile certaines choses sur
thor la formation tort ils n'aiment pas
trop
je sais pas en fait si tu veux de
certaines bandes passantes qui se trouve
près l'ambassade pour aspirer du trafic
qui ont des choses comme ça c'est c'est
pour toi ça reste que des ragots c'est
pas des ragots cd on dit c'est quoi
écoute enfin
le problème si tu veux que dans à partir
du moment où tu as une activité
connue où tu as une activité bien
identifiés où tu as ta pignon sur rue ou
tu fais non un peu comme toi
il ya des choses si tu veux ya des
compromis à faire
aucun compromis mais peut-être mais
d'autres personnes peuvent décider que
ce compromis l'un n'est pas suffisamment
critique pour qu'on ne le fasse pas faim
tu vois ce que je veux dire c'est tu
penses que la fondation tort fait des
compromis jeu
[Musique]
c'est grave moi non je dis que c'est
parce que je dise enfin sans armand je
suis très peu je me tiens exprès très
peu au courant des problématiques de
personnes entre à personne de jacob
appelbaum douce amère par exemple qui a
été qu'ils aient fait un
problème enfin qu' un truc extrêmement
clivant pour la communauté et ce n'est
toujours pas fini enfin je veux dire la
communauté au sens très large et les
durablement elle sera durablement
affectés par ce problème là y'a qu'à
voir
le film de leur appui trace sur
wikileaks
elle a eu il n'a fait elle a une liaison
avec apple balle qui est dans le film
et si tu veux tu as outre la guéguerre
de réputation et cetera entre wikileaks
et l'équipe de leur abri traces
extérieures tu as aussi ce genre de
conflit
on va dire pas d'intérêt mais des
conflits plus interpersonnelles qui
viennent s'ajouter en fait ajouter aussi
que c est ce que ces conflits
interpersonnels
sont instrumentalisés par des puissances
extérieures ou des services extérieurs
je pense pas en fait ce qu'il faut voir
avec la fin
des problèmes interpersonnels il y aura
il y en aura toujours enfin il ya eu
toujours et c'est ce qu'il faut voir en
fait c'est pas tellement que quelqu'un a
besoin de
l'instrumentaliser c'est qu'on le fait
déjà très bien quand les gens commencent
à prendre parti
ça ça clive confiant son temps oui oui
enfin tu utilises quoi pour chiffrer ces
informations tu fais tu chiffres comment
je suis obligé de te dire pas tout de
suite mais on est d'accord c'est un
petit as tu veux qu'on devienne intime
en plus
ok
parlons du bitcoin alors bitcoin qu'est
ce qu'on en pense qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait on le garde précieusement et on
attend que ça atteignent les dix mille
balles dans la boue coût
42 fatiguer un peu ta 42 bitcoin or 42
la réponse
c'est un apprenti classique
les qu'est ce que tu penses de l'éther
d' agent n'est aussi pareil achetez
maintenant remercier mois plus tard
pourquoi
parce qu'il ya une vraie communauté
derrière il ya énormément de projets
qui embarquent en flic utilise extérieur
les terres et enfin par exemple enfin
beaucoup de gens te dire oui mais alors
tu comprends le beach boys et du
scripting simple on ne peut pas faire
grand chose c'est ya juste une valeur
monétaire associé avec nana na na avec
les terres tu as tu as tout le reste tu
as une
un véhicule si tu veux de transactions
de toutes sortes et et ajoutent les
smart contracte où les contrats autonome
à ça donc tu as vraiment un
[Musique]
un écosystème on va dire technique
qui est certes jeune et immature encore
mettant un éco système révolutionnaire
si tu veux technique qui avec lequel on
pourra commencer à faire des trucs
intéressants je crois vraiment à la
blocs chaîne a pas à la bloquer enfin
aux blocs et une 6e ce que la blog team
bon c'était le buzz l'un dernier info
aujourd'hui faute tu te met à jour ses
intelligences artificielles les robots
vont nous envahir skynet où ça tu tu
veux en parler non pourquoi est-ce que
tu suis un peu ce qui se passe dans
l'université de manchester
pas spécialement tu parles de quoi dans
des gens' artificiel
tu veux qu'on parle de quoi avachi pas
motivé par les sex-toys bien ça pour la
fin on parle à s'excuser ou se connecter
à la fin qu'est ce que tu entends par le
dip web rien pour moi ça ne devrait pas
exister
qu'est ce que les gens entendent par le
dip web
le web non référencés par google
bien
wizard pour vulgariser tu m'a dit
si tu veux ça a été une grande question
quand
quand j'ai écrit parce qu'il ya
exactement un paragraphe sur le dip web
parce que c'est une expression que les
gens connaissent et que les gens
utilisent je n'ai pas dit qu'il dit ça
colle donc voilà à nantes amis dark web
parce qu'on attend sinon je serais pas
venu tu penses pas mais
en fait si tu veux les dents sur la page
wikipedia qui fait office de référence
que tout le monde lit sans la citer ses
marques et que c'est la partie
d'internet que les moteurs de recherche
classiques n'indexe pas ce qui était
probablement une définition correcte en
2002 en 2017 et en fait quand les gens
commencent et expliquer ce qu'ils
comprennent d'après la page wikipedia de
ce qu'est le dip web tu te rends compte
surtout qu'on veut enfin qu'on n'a
jamais explique comment fonctionne un
moteur de recherche c'est surtout ça en
fait du coup pour - la position que je
défends enfin que je défendrai c'est de
complètement
mettre à la poubelle cette expression là
qui n'a aucun sens que oui il ya
certaines un certain contenu qui sont
pas indexable par un moteur de recherche
parce que vous quitte les robots qui
viennent d indexer voilà par exemple tu
vois non là on attend qu'ils deviennent
tu vois qu'ils commencent à faire le
café tout ça
mais non mais plus sérieusement en fait
c'est ça aucune
des réalités techniques au sens où
la manière à fonctionner un moteur de
recherche c'est la manière d'un moteur
de recherche points et après tout ce
truc là ce mélange très très vite de
manière très habile est assez
impressionnante ces fascinantes avec un
canular partie de fortune qui parle de
icebergs et les fautes explique que le
for child farkas
il va y avoir du new look qui vas voir
ta vidéo donc il faut que tu expliques
tous deux d'accord alors forte chan seth
s'éteint c'est là où on perd confiance
dans l'humanité mais non mais non
maintenant des coûts ya partout des
normes est bonne mais je sais que
forte chan c'est un forum de discussion
allez on va le dire très très vite où il
ya bas comme dans toute forme de
discussion il ya tout plein de gens qui
discutent et il ya certains
certains recoins de ce forum qui sont
pas spécialement pour des âmes sensibles
où on peut effectivement si on est un
peu trop déprimé perdre confiance à
l'humanité voilà bon après il ya
énormément c'est ces deux là en fait qui
est partie anonymes ou singe est parti
le collectif qui après devenu un
anonymous externe j'explique
aujourd'hui farchana existe toujours
c'est toujours un forum de discussion
très très moche pour les gens qui sont
habitués à des interfaces web
super clan quand je lis et où classe
très moche mais c'est pas grave parce
que en fait ce qui compte c'est les
échanges entre les gens qui sont pour la
plupart avec qui ne donnent pas leur nom
leur pseudo parce qu'il fait en fait
qu'il y à des échanges houleux capital
social n'a aucune valeur on s'en fout
royalement de savoir qui tu es ce qui
est plus important c'est c'est le coup
de la teneur de ce que tu racontes est
donc forte jeunes étaient connus comme
le repaire des trickster des clowns ddd
procter enfin voir
tu peux d'ailleurs enfin hills et esprit
persiste un tout petit peu encore si
ancian fouille bien
et en fait il ya des années sur farfan
quelqu'un a créé cette espèce de de
désinformation
avec un énorme iceberg comme ça et en
expliquant les niveaux du d'internet et
donc il y en a chez plus une à cinq ou
six avec le plus profond et un le
mariana ce web un référence fawcett na
heireann qui est le point le plus
profond sur terre et donc le mariannaute
web c'est le l'internet le plus profond
et donc ils ont raconté que pour aller
dans le marianne as web et bah il faut
un fal'cie goal dérivatif polymère ge
plus quoi qui est une invention pure et
simple et les mecs raconté de
l'informatique quantique est pas tout le
monde hier 1 est revenu c'est un canular
est donc là tu as toutes sortes de
légendes qui traînent urbaine que tu
trouverais les archives du docteur
menguele et le
le tortionnaire en chef des nazis qu'on
trouverait les
l'emplacement de l'atlantide eux les
archives privées du vatican
toutes les légendes possibles et
imaginables et donc en fait cette notion
de dix poèmes elle se mêle allègrement
avec cette espèce de
de canulars fascinant de d'icebergs et
un gros
beaucoup de gens qui veulent expliquer
ou prétend de faire de la vulgarisation
vont allègrement mélangé les deux te
raconter que par exemple le dip web
c'est le premier niveau en dessous de
l'océan tu
vas où tu vas par exemple trouver de la
recherche en mathématiques quand tu
entends des politiques qui veulent
réguler l'internet mais bah y'en a qui
ont essayé ils ont eu des problèmes tu
vois
non mais c'était drôle et il ya j'étais
à
une table ronde à l'itunes
qu'institution internationale des
télécommunications à la mi juin et il y
avait un garçon un avocat quitter la
table ronde avec moi qui voulais
absolument faire une juridiction darknet
ah oui non c'était c'était magique à si
haut bref tout kg je lis répondu que y'a
macchio et ses îlots et des problèmes il
n'a pas compris la requérante
mais voilà c'est en fait l'idée que
j'essaie de promouvoir avec le livre
entre autres mais plus largement c'est
que
être sur internet ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui de manière très courante cls
et c'est une activité aussi quotidiennes
que boire de l'eau aller faire ses
courses dormir faire d'autres choses
moins
voilà
c est une activité aussi ordinaire que
ça donc essayer de réguler certains
usages du quotidien
par une juridiction particulière un
interdit bien aux gens de fumer dans les
bars oui d'accord très bien mais est-ce
qu'on interdit pourtant la cigarette ce
qu'on interdit de terrorisme sur
internet tu peux toujours essayer mais
c'est difficile un petit peu l'internet
c'est le terrorisme c'est un sophisme
je parle comme un politique ah oui non
mais là trop l'évent 42 quoi il faut
mais non non pourquoi pourquoi ils le
disent tout le temps pourquoi ils disent
que l'internet favorise le terrain
pourquoi pourquoi on a fait une loi
renseignements pourquoi ce qu'il faut un
bouc émissaire un et que qu'elle le bouc
émissaire un le cryptage de telegraaf
chiffrement nam et à je te parle comme
une politique excuse toi
c'est c'est le cryptage de télégrammes
qui tu vois favorise
le terrorisme est fait que les gens
automatiquement
il se réveille le matin et ils veulent
faire péter des bombes artisanales sur
les champs-elysées il faut un bouc
émissaire c'est
en fait que ce que je recommande
aux gens qui me regardent de lire un
article très concis et très bien écrit
de jeff mathiot sur reflets
qui si ma mémoire est bonne s'appelle
chiffre augmente de points les temps
panique
qui en fait explique justement
ce qui se cache derrière ce genre de
rhétorique très
très anxiogène très
culpabilisante et ses terrains de 1,1
outils techniques ou un médium ou en
l'occurrence le chiffrement cdma tu
crées est une activité criminelle
extrêmement extrêmement importante
extrêmement agressive donc et donc je
vous paye pas faudra les lire mais voilà
un grand lit c'est ce que j'essaye
d'expliquer c'est qu'on est en plein
milieu de la 2e crypto à la deuxième
guerre du chiffrement la première était
dans les années 90 où pgp c'était
illégal
voilà
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
autres où
il y à une mobilisation très générale de
la part de tout plan de politiciens et
de tout plan de législateurs
contre quelque chose qu'ils identifient
comme le problème qu'ils sont mal
conseillé ou ils sont mal conseillé à
dessein
je pense qu'ils ont déconseillé tout à
fait capable
ouais mais pas je sais que ça sortira
pas d'internet mais quand même
non je pense qu'ils sont bien conseillé
après
je vais pas spoiler les raisons mais
comme jeff le l'expliquent enfin le
montre bien dans son article il y à une
stratégie politique derrière qui
laquelle est latent j'ai dit je vais pas
spoiler
vous allez lire un an maintenant mais si
je fais pas de la pub pour mes potes
quand tu vois certains états
comme les états unis avec le killswitch
quand tu vois vladimir poutine qui veut
mettre la fin à tort vpn à tous les
proxy qui veut
on va dire mettre la main sur
le secret des correspondances quand tu
vois la chine et son great firewall
ça te fait penser à quoi tout ça on se
dirige vers quoi
wen vers le mur quoi c'est un fait
j'ai combien
je suis un peu je commence un peu à
déprimer
sérieusement enfin parce que la dite
c'est le type de discussion qu'on avait
il ya cinq ans
après snowden du cou ou en fait on était
quelqu'un on essaie d'expliquer aux gens
que la ceinture ça va enfin je veux dire
il ya des moyens de contourner la
censure
ce qui était beaucoup plus dangereux
parce qu'il est toujours c'est la
surveillance est ce que la surveillance
oui aujourd'hui c'est un truc super
courant tout le monde va dire ouais nan
mais c'est bon moi j'ai rien à cacher je
sais pas quoi
parce que c'est tellement rentrée
notamment postaux des instruments
rentrée en fait dans les consciences
qu'on se rend pas compte comme en nos
noms nos propres
dans comportement ouest en organisation
sa pensée il y à pas la grande forme
isation de la pia et normalisation si tu
veux ou normaux potel pathol y
voilà
moi j'avais faim j'utilise le monde
normaux pattes mais voilà oui bah j'aime
bien créer des mots
dorothy picus si tu veux après voilà on
n'est pas là pour faire
calife à la place du calife au docteur à
la place de coeur mais en fait il ya il
ya une vraie problématique de modulation
du comportement qui est là par la
surveillance et tu n'as pas de telles de
telles pressions de normalisation et de
rentrer à ge d'un moule fête qui en fait
a exercé par la censure ce qu'on sait
toujours que
sous le rsd qu'il y avait les services
date tu vas y tu avais tu passais
beaucoup de choses sous le manteau et
puis basta quand tu quand tu vois la
surveillance si si j'avais ce micro là
toute la journée sur moi 24 24 7 jours
sur 7 un téléphone portable branché
peut-être mais c'est différent tu vois
mais si j'avais un micro sur moi
branchés sur internet un broadcast toute
la journée sept jours sur sept il ya
beaucoup de choses que je ne dirais pas
comme quoi
la liste des dix derniers partenaires
sexuels
je suis désolé mais pas trop
non plus mais la renommée en fait il ya
énormément de choses qu'on ne ferait pas
si on savait que quelqu'un enfin que
n'importe qui en fait tu peux nous
entendre à n'importe quel moment il ya
une notion de fans de l'intimité qui est
là et qui en fait fait énorme faim fait
vraiment une véritable pression
d'autocensure sur juste beaucoup de
chance qu est-ce que l'autocensure après
c'était pas le retour de m de
compétences est-ce que l'autocensure
radical radicalise certains
ça dépend de ce que tu appelles
radicaliser tu vois il est le toussaint
sur par exemple moi ça m'a fait quitter
certains réseaux sociaux tu t'es
radicaliser je ne suis pas un radicalisé
mais j'ai pris une décision radicale
ça dépend vraiment de comment tu définis
la radicalisation mais si physiquement
il ya il ya il ya des endroits où si tu
veux mais interaction a été juste
insupportable quoi sans aucun intérêt la
plupart du temps des gens qui t'agresse
ceux qui parlent mal extraordinaire qui
fait bon bah le bilan pour moi il est
négatif je me casse quoi mais c'est une
forme d'autocensure tirer tirer ou pour
éviter de te faire surveiller à bavent
j'aimerais bien savoir où tu vas le truc
c'est que comment est ce que tu évites
de te faire surveiller j'ai quelques
petites idées oui non mais moi aussi tu
vas la question est que oui on peut tous
se mettre des freins des trucs sur le
visage se mettre des cheveux bizarres et
c'est ok admettons pour tromper la
reconnaissance faciale que ça marche
plus a maintenant avec les saints la
vidéosurveillance il analyse son
comportement tout mouvement je peux
aussi mais là la pub le fait déjà pour
toi donc enfin pour eux ouvrent à où
qu'ils soient mais tata un autre
protéine problématique qui et comment il
ya une différence énorme entre 1,1 et
limité
et et
et le fait de ne pas être surveillés si
je sors dans la rue jean cagoule sur la
tête oui bah tu vas pas à reconnaître
mon visage par contre je me suis fait
retirer tue un bas je risque de me faire
tirer dessus de toute façon les gens
vont me voir donc quand je suis par
contre rien à nîmes mais est ce que ma
tendance quand on se fond dans la foule
est-ce qu'il faut intoxiqués ou est-ce
qu'il faut devenir invisible et est ce
que quand tu deviens invisible tu
deviens d'autant plus visible c'est ça
tu vas tu peux acheter des des pochettes
là
qui isole complètement ton téléphone
temps le voilà sur sur amazon ou tu veux
ouais bah c'est cool du coup tu
disparais d'arada à des endroits
particuliers à des moments particuliers
ça te fait d'autant plus visible c'est
pour ça que le chiffrement et le fait
d'être un anonyme sur le web aux freins
sur internet c'est ça peut te rendre
extrêmement remarquables ou parce qu'ils
aient tort comme utilisateur ça peut te
rendre extrêmement un remarquable située
à rares
d'où en fait plus de gens il y en a qui
utilisent ces outils là plus il ya une
masse critique qui fait que personne ne
peut-on extraire parce que tu as un
comportement différent mais le problème
si tu veux c'est comment est-ce que tu
établi un comportement classique ça veut
dire quoi aller sur facebook tout le
temps avec son vrai nom
cliquez sur des pubs de temps à autres
j'en sais rien moi est en fait le fait
20 plus ça va avec tout les traqueurs de
toutes sortes que qu'on a autour de nous
plus en fait le fait d' à vous de
d'être visible sans être identifiable 1
revient à commettre le crime parfait de
manière répétée quotidienne et ça je ne
sais pas enfin je ne pense pas que
quelqu'un sache faire ça tu milites pour
qu'il y ait une
agence de régulation de l'algorithme
dirait bon c'est mal formulé un conseil
supérieur de comment ils font pour nous
traquer qu'est-ce qu'ils utilisent comme
tracker macally comment ça s'appelle
déjà paye allait y aller à la cnil et à
le conseil national du numérique fin
juillet c'est à la cnil a ouvert la lgo
de google ah non mais là c'est une
entreprise privée dont tu parle et ça
après tout ce qu on est en train de
confier notre vie ou privés non mais
c'est déjà fait t'es sûr est ce que
l'état est ce que l'état est moins ce
qu'il en reste fais quelque chose pour
essayer de récupérer ses pouvoirs
régaliens
attention parce que après il ya d'autres
questions je vais jouer l'avocat du
diable mais est ce que tu préfères que
ce soit l'état qui s'interpose
quitte à ce qu'il récupère
certains d'une solution sans la femme de
l'est un carré blanc je vois pas du tout
de quoi tu parles
non mais il ya une vraie question là
dedans tu vas est-ce que tu confierait
une
partie non négligeable du pouvoir qui
aujourd'hui concentrée chez les gars
femme un google amazon apple facebook
tout ça est ce que tu le confierait à
ton état
je ne sais pas je dis pas que les gars
femmes c'est mieux que l'étain nuls
inverse est ce que tu penses pas que
google et la pointe de diamant de l'état
américain pour l'interception de données
aussi avec lui fin peu
non enfin j'ai dit il ya
il ya suffisamment de manière de
collecter de la donnée à caractère
personnel et personnelle des gens qui
qu'il soit
que t'as pas besoin de un acteur en
particulier enfin je dis ça n'a plus de
sens là où
là aussi tu vends se rendent compte des
différences d'approché de ce que ça veut
dire de
d'être le maître d'un moteur de
recherche c'est quand tu regardes la
russie et nous ce qui nous l'europe de
l'ouest on va dire ou enfin le monde
occidental en russie c'est le seul pays
où tu as les équivalents de ce qui
existe
un réseaux sociaux un moteur de
recherche ex ex 1 mais ça existe et
c'est fait maison
pourquoi parce que ils se sont rendus
très très tôt compte que être le
gatekeeper le gardien en fait des
demandes de des questionnements des gens
est un est un pouvoir juste sans
précédent et sans commune mesure quoi ou
contrôle de data drôle mais c'est même
pas une question de contrôle de data
c'est google
si tu veux il sait exactement quel doute
tu habites le doute tu habites année 1,1
seulement
voilà à quelles sont tes deux à un
moment donné
parce que au lieu dit tu fais plus de
mots clés tu tapes une vraie question
dans le truc de recherche donc il ya en
fait énormément de
d'information s'est même pas donné
d'informations qui sont collectés comme
ça je renseignements mais si tu veux
mais
ils la contrôlent mieux la contre-mesure
peut être la structure fine derrière
c'est ça pour influencer des exemples
après tu peux avoir plein de plein de
choses qui sont en fait à ce à quoi la
structure fine pour toi là la structure
fine gueule à la structure fine goût
j'ai entendu la str6 donne son avis
c'est vrai
juste avant de passer sur ça
on peut parler de plans d'acteurs de ce
qu'ils font machin ce qui me paraît
important si tu veux d'un dans cette
discussion c'est de parler de ce qu'on
appelle le modèle de menaces est en fait
de savoir contre qui tu veux te protéger
aujourd'hui une partie non négligeable
des choses qu'on va conseiller aux gens
c'est un ayant en tête essayez de vous
protéger contre l année ça
voilà ça c'est très très ambitieux et en
fait
laiterie break et ça marche pas voilà
donc il y à il ya des situations où
quand quand on va dire chiffres de mail
ok très bien tu veux les prêts tu veux
protéger ce contenu là de petits
exactement
donc il ya vraiment c'est cet aspect là
qui manquent de 2,2 d'un nombre non
négligeable de
d'initiatives de sensibilisation etc qui
est de dire qui en fait contrer qui je
veux de qui je vais me cacher
c'est par exemple
tiens points personnels quand il m'avait
la première fois qu'est ce qu'elle la
question que je te pose est comment
est-ce qu'être commentait le bon numéro
mais c'était pas une question je t'ai
répondu quoi tu m'a dit je te dirai
après tu imagines jambes voilà n'avait
pas grave de bras ouais non non je sais
exactement où se trouvait mon numéro ah
mais pas pourquoi parce que je veux
savoir en fait
je veux savoir à tout moment ce qui
connut deux mois
parce qu'il ya une personne je sais
depuis plusieurs années qui
ce que tu consommes occupent non
t'inquiète j'ai des copains avec une
propension pour les genoux et les battes
de base-ball ça va c'est gérer
mais je plaisante
ça c'était d'ailleurs mais ça marche si
oui non mais plus sérieusement parce que
y'a une différence moi personnellement
je veux savoir à peu près à tout moment
où il ya des informations personnelles
sur moi qui se promènent et donc si
elles sont publiques extérieures à
savoir que baverel internet peut en
avoir accès au vaccin ok très bien donc
en fait c'est pour ça que j'étais poser
cette question là mais dans mon modèle
de menace c'est voilà quelqu'un qui ne
me connaît pas vraiment peut trouver mon
numéro de téléphone où tu l'as trouvé tu
sais comment questionnaire
extérieur donc
ça c'est un modèle de menace c'est je
veux savoir à tout moment une personne
qui ne me connaît pas ce qu'elle peut
trouver deux mois et elle le trouve
qu'est ce que tu vas tu vas me dire
après
ce protégé de la haine et ça c'est une
gageur enfin je veux dire se protéger
d'un acteur étatique ou d'un acteur qui
a des oeuvres de grandeur de plus fins
de pouvoir plus de pouvoir que la place
soit stockage de l'analyse c'est un
problème qu'est ce que tu penses des
logiciels prédictif
abbas et bien mineure et qui reparaît
report c'était bien
ça votre question sacre en sacrant une
question internet salorges avec la lyre
tel quel internet est il incompatible
sur certains points avec la vie in rio
life dans le sens où la liberté de
parole et d'action sur le web peut poser
des problèmes dans sa vie in real life
entre parenthèses travail fisc je
rajouterais assurances il est plein
d'autres
si tu menaces quelqu'un dans la rue et
si tu le menace sur sur twitter les
répercussions peuvent sont
potentiellement les mêmes ce que c'est
les mêmes lois qui s'appliquent si je
décide de porter plainte contre x pour
menaces
bas que ce soit sur twitter ou dans la
rue c'est pareil et ici je te menace
c'est que je suis caché au kazakhstan
derrière
25 ip différente est ce que tu vas
pouvoir me retrouver
si je t'envoie lé soin de le soit chez
toi le soit chez moi si je suis du soin
thing chez toi et vite j'ai un très beau
parquet j'aimerais que ça aille
très gentil sera ajouté à une autre
question quels réseaux sociaux at elle
quitté quelques les réseaux sociaux a tu
quittais dirait-il debout comme
mastodonte
toi je te retrouverai
je boirai taguine s
est jeté à terre et paille offre
donc on dit bonjour à benjamin tesquet
jolie benjamin alors est-ce que j'ai des
tongs je n'ai pas de temps ça c'est un
private joke
on va continuer sur sur ce chemin-là les
activistes la quadrature
ceux qui se refusent la santé pour
éplucher des textes de loi
est ce qu'ils n'en sont pas tellement
réduit qu'ils en deviennent juste
inopérant ou juste c'est le canari dans
la mine
non je dirais pas qu'ils sont a réduit
la quadrature a beaucoup changé un
grande partie grâce à adrian qui est
nous quitte
pour aller a lancé je l' ai mis mon nom
c'est pas la donne à l'insistance et pas
l'ennemi arrêté n'est pas l'ennemi on
dit bonjour à ayew dont pailloux
n'y a eu un vrai travail fdt de fait si
tu veux de recalibrage des engagements
donc du discours qui va avec et c'est
parce que perso j'avais été très frustré
ya des années quand le focus de la
quadrature était extrêmement européen et
international que la place était en fait
laissé vacante en france et il y avait
il y avait personne pour reprendre le
flambeau c'est enfin personnellement
c'était une grande frustration
et aujourd'hui si tu veux je suis
rassuré de savoir que ces gens sont là
que
qu'il veut mais pas seulement qui veille
au grain made in the sentinel d'une
manière très active en fait et tu vas si
des gens se demande que faire pendant
les vacances scolaires ou autres
c'est n'hésitez pas à les rejoindre à
contribuer ne serait ce que deux heures
par semaine c'est déjà énorme et parce
que après plus on est de fous plus on
rit que ce soit les exégètes que ce soit
la quadrature et cetera que soit regards
citoyens enfin juste il ya plein de
d'initiative de structures qui sont qui
font un travail mais juste exceptionnel
de fond et qu'on ne remarque pas
nécessairement tout le temps
parce que
grâce à eux il ya des choses qu'ils
progressent sauf que on ne les voit pas
faire
et on se dit ça va mais objecte alors tu
ne fais pas pour faire partie de la
quadrature mais tu as dû souvent on
tombe ça
ou leur object
d'avoir été ou d'être financés par soros
a mais après si tu donnes l'oreille à
toutes sortes de théories de
conspirationnistes c'est un problème la
quadrature c'est en revient à notre
discussion de tout à l'heure sur la
privatisation de l'action civique la
quadrature une des seules organisations
au monde qui ne fonctionne que sur les
dons il n'y a pas de financement privé à
la quadrature il n'y a pas de alors ils
le cachent super bien même on envoie là
s'est il n'y a pas de financement privé
c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas une
organisation qui l'y a bondi de 12 ans
voilà qui dit je vous donne un jeu vous
donne tant par contre en échange
aujourd'hui le caniveau petit veau petit
votre petite cuisine mais par contre ça
ça et ça c'est des conditions que je
pose pour vous donner des sous ça ça
n'existe pas chez la quadrature est donc
encore une fois le cette liberté là elle
est extrêmement rare
on a tout est le seul à en discussion
sur thor etc beaucoup de gens vont te
dire que thor est quand même financé par
un nombre non négligeable de
d'organisations nationales
gouvernementale d'institutions
gouvernementales ou de gros bailleur de
fonds qui concentrent quand même un nom
une quantité non négligeable de la tune
qui aujourd'hui donnée aux secteurs de
la société civile
voilà après c'est pour ça que j'essaye
de ne pas aller dans cette discussion là
parce qu'il ya tellement de théories de
conspiration qui sont super facile à
monter et
à
propager et que je vois regardons les
actions des gens cette histoire de soros
c'est une histoire qui est très marrante
si tu veux les conspirationnistes en
europe de l'est moyen orient c'est leur
cible préférée seront de toute façon ou
en raison de toute façon dès qu'il ya un
problème des finances et par soros
points et c'est assez marrant de voir
que depuis un certain temps depuis
l'élection d'un certain monsieur 1 qui a
transformé les états unis d'amérique en
30 piston
entre en piste en voilà tu as en fait
une pénétration
hallucinant de sept de ses théories du
complot en france aussi on va te dire
que toute façon toi quand tu fais des
trucs qui te plaisent pas à une telle
des finances et par soir aux sas et
l'insultent ultima enfin on va passer
mais le sujet le journalisme et
l'internet
ça te fait penser à quoi est-ce que tu
trouves que les journalistes sont
suffisamment formés pour parler de ce
qu'ils essayent de raconter ce que tu
penses que les journalistes aussi seront
peut-être un peu responsable de cette
défiance et cette montée en puissance
des fêtes news c'est quoi ton avis alors
je te donne peut-être la réponse dans la
question va
alors pour les fêtes mais attention j'ai
l'est oblige
[Musique]
cette histoire de fakes news elle est
particulière parce que qu'on ce qu'on
cherche à faire qu'il soit on skie level
dureront le but recherché
ce n'est pas tant que ça de propos j'ai
une information fausse est monté de
toutes pièces mais de rendre
les faits ou en état de fait plus ou
moins découvrable est identifiable
vérifiables et c'est de le rendre
impossibles à vérifier impossible à
distinguer de n'importe quoi d'autre en
fait le mot anglais de pour ça c'est un
eurobond tu ne peux pas en fait tu que
tu ne sois pas mesure de distinguer le
vrai du faux le l'exagèrent est du réel
etc c'est beaucoup plus dangereux que
monter un bidule de toutes pièces je
veux dire moi aussi je peux tu as
inventé 30000 la journée sauf qu'elle
est les caves de les grottes de tora
bora va'a well et des armes de
destruction massive la mémé tu vas
typiquement cette idée cette histoire de
thor et de ses prétendues ou palmer tort
quand même c'est il ya quand même des
faisceaux de présomptions qui sont quand
même vachement important et je me
permets je me permets de le dire d'un
sens où
certains de nos potes
relativement techniquement des modèles
avec les doigts dedans quand on commence
à mettet doigt dedans dès fois les
adhérents sont si révélatrice bon
passons on fera une émission dédiée à ce
sujet je veux bien
tu vas en fait c'est le truc pour
continuer sur les journalistes du coup
la question est les lie at elle en fait
l'idée des fakes enfin parce que quand
tu veux faire la propagande sais tu te
dis tu te débrouilles à ce que
toutes les informations qu'elle soit
vraie fausse semi vrai semi fossés etc
et le même degré
de de crédit fin de confiance même degré
de crédibilité et c
est ça c'est super compliqué ça
s'appelle le side up ce tu l'appelles
comme tu veux mais voilà c'est un truc
connu vingt c'est un truc qui était très
tres bien fait en europe de l'est oui
l'otan aussi sont très forts et
on va parler sextoys et civique tech tu
veux commencer par quoi tous les ir
d'achat ou machines à voter non à des
machines à voter
au bon marché unique en perspective
coeur balance non mais c'est bon il n'y
a pas de marché public la
cia un rapport du sénat je vais te
retrouves et même là j'ai un long
entretien sur ça
et il y a
un problème il ya un rapport du sénat je
crois de 2008
où si tu veux il est marqué noir sur
blanc
qu'il est nécessaire de ouvrez les
guillemets est réglé le sort des
machines à voter en france point fermez
les guillemets rapport du sénat
moi j'en suis très contente parce que le
vote électronique
c'est juste hors de question
et pour plein de raisons mais
une idée très bête si tu veux avec le
vote électronique
outre
les exigences de
dan limitée du vote
c'est le fait de pouvoir expliquer
comment ça marche à n'importe qui
pourquoi parce que c'est un droit
civique de base c'est-à-dire
fondamentale et donc toute personne
doit être en mesure de comprendre
comment l'exercer
avec le vote papier c'est très très
simple tu prends la feuille tu la mets
dans l' enveloppe
de préférence
que parce qu'un personne ne regarde et
bâle enveloppe tu la glisse dans une
urne de préférence transparentes pour
éviter les bourrages d'urnes de plus
après dépouillement machin tout le monde
peut rencontrer les feuilles pas très
compliqué tu prends voilà avec le vote
électronique
vas-y essayé d'expliquer la crypto
l'électronique
l'immatériel l'authentification métiers
de la totale essaye d'expliquer ça à
quelqu'un
si tu incites a déjà lu des procès
verbaux ou des choses comme ça suite à
des élections tu as des trucs absolument
marrante dedans ou
l'observation de sécurité et donc
la condition de non bourrages d'urnes
quoi un gros c'est les scrutateurs ont
pu observer les machines à voter toute
la journée
ah oui kg doute en est là tu te dis ah
bah oui c'est sûr que
sas a garanti qui a pas de bourrage
d'urnes
changeait rien les majeures pas d'audit
de code
non l'entreprise qui fabrique ces trucs
là ne te permet pas de le faire après
même eau qui tu vas faire un guide du
code admettons parce que là je sors je
sais qui a plein de gens qui vont dire
oui mais tu comprends avec logiciel
libre ça se règle ben ouais admettons et
l'audit du hardware tu vas le faire
comment
la crypto tu va la faire comment
la fin il ya juste l'électronique tu va
la faire comment il ya juste eu plein de
trucs en fait qu'ils ne peuvent pas être
réglés juste parce qu'on veut bien quoi
6 du genre à gueuler genre un peu comme
les baux d'électronique ne mange pas un
certificat d'authentification
ça pourrait pas marcher non plus tu as
des as en fait
tu pourrais faire ça
il ya qu'est-ce qui me parlait de ça
récemment il y a une approche si tu veux
je veux dire des conneries techniques en
jeu prévient attention que je te faire
battre
je vais me faire mettre coin de rue
au attention et je dois
maintenant il ya en fait ce qu'il te
faut quand tu quand si tu veux vraiment
faire ça à condition de mettre de côté
l'expliquent habilités de la chose ce
qu'il te faut c'est pouvoir en fait
compter
sans connecter le vote à une personne
est sain il commence à y avoir des
approches techniques
du
faut vérifier parce que je peux me
centrer voilà du chiffrement home
orphique je crois que ça s'appelle mais
je vois là merci de vérifier et de pas
me tenir rigueur si je dis des conneries
mais en gros si tu veux c'est ok si on
met de côté le fait de ne pas pouvoir
expliquer exactement ce qui se passe
on pourrait éventuellement arriver
techniquement à une situation où tu peux
compter sans savoir à qui appartient le
vote est un étang sûr que la personne a
bien mis un bulletin enfin pas bien
voter parce que tu as ça aussi qui est
problématique donc les civic t qui aura
d'autant ajouté écoute j'ai beaucoup
bossé dans les six vitesses justement
avant de revenir un peu plus
sérieusement en france c'est à dire
entre quoi
2012 et
2015 2016
c'est bien c'est bien mais
le regarde regarde l'open data prenons
l'open data et il ya eu énormément
d'efforts faits pour l'ouverture des
données publiques
est ce qu'un est-ce que ça a vraiment
est ce qu'on a vraiment tiré une
véritable valeur de ces données là est
ce qu on le fait toujours est-ce combien
elles sont utilisées ces données là ça
va peut-être venir les smart grid de
machin tout ça c'est marseille des td
pour la consommation énergétique ça a
pété les portables tout un tas de choses
je me fais l'avocat du diable qui t'ai
dit que ces dernières seront ouvertes et
public alors il faudra demander à la
remplaçant d'axel le maire
mounir mahjoubi on va bientôt le soir
dernière question durant avant dernière
question les objets connectés oui alors
on tu veux qu'on discute frigo connectés
ou boules de geisha connectés dildo je
préfère dildo dildo mes grands ou petits
deals de plastique porcelaine un live il
aurait fallu mettre dans un camp sur sur
la vidéo on va passer cette question là
j'ai pas assez bu pour y répondre et vu
que je viens de l'est franchement je
viens t'asseoir des litres voilà donc
faut se lever très tôt non en fait j'ai
pourquoi j'ai choisi cette histoire de
sex-toys connectés justement parce que
oui les blagues s'écrivent tout seul
mais les blagues graveleuses de bonne
qualité j'entends quand on dit joe klein
non pas d'un bouquin les sextoys
connectés j'ai commencé à parler après
avoir fini ça remonte à quand faut que
tu t'es fait acquitter bull jamais
jamais elles sont c'est moi qui ai les
audits donc si si je suis pas contente
je les utilise pas
certains beauchamp croit parce que je
vois
pas 100 bougies
oui bien c'est un risque tous ces objets
connectés oui en fait bon pour continuer
sur cette histoire de pourquoi les eaux
les sex-toys c'est vrai que c'est pas du
tout un sujet facile parler de sexualité
de manière aussi ouverte
avec des blagues le plus souvent drôle
mais pas tout le temps pourquoi parce
que ça permet de poser différentes
questions que ce soit la sécurité que ce
soit la notion d'intimité de vie privée
à la vie privée aujourd'hui on la
balance comme une espèce de blocs
d'obsidian comme ça google niveau mais
là c'est trop trop trop la cata
attention votre vie privée attaquer mais
dans la notion de vie privée il ya plein
d'aspects différents qui ne se résume
pas un bloc d'obsidienne attention parce
qu'en fait le bloc bas quand tu l'as
dans le chemin tu fais quoi soit tu tape
dedans et tu passes avec beaucoup de
d'efforts et c'est à travers soit tu
qu'on tourne et il se passe quoi
aujourd'hui un plongeon qui contourne
donc cette histoire de sex-toys
connectés c'est parce que quand tu en
parles pour la première fois plein de
gens te disent mais moi ça me
traumatiserait vraiment de me faire un
quai
dil domont vibrant fin juin c'est god
will go de ce que tu veux là ce que tu
utilises je sais pas et en fait il y
réfléchit c'est ce disent oui mais en
fait à six à dix fonctionne pas je
l'enlève quoi donc si je si en fait
quelqu'un a pris le contrôle à distance
et que je sens que ça fonctionne pas
comme je veux moi je fais quoi c'est un
objet sur lequel j'ai le contrôle je
l'enlève points
ok
les sex-toys connectés se font partie
des objets connectés à visée médicale
en maintenant pense de ton sextoys que
quelqu'un va compromettre et donc
contrôler à distance si c'était un
pacemaker là c'est un peu moins drôle
quand même tu as au ton frigo le petit
choc anaphylactique tu le vois venir
voilà donc si tu veux parler des sex
toys ça fait réfléchir à plusieurs
niveaux et quand même c'est plus sexy
c'est un jeu de mots que le frigo quoi
parce que combien de gens vont si tu
annonces on va parler
on va parler frigo connecte sécurité des
frigos connectés je te paraît que tu vas
avoir vent 20 personnes qui vont
regarder si on dit sex-toys tu vas en
avoir comme les voitures connectées
là tu as aussi vain tu as plein de
problèmes dont certains sont liés à ça
mais tu as tu as aussi on revient à
cette histoire d'algues au et donc de
kiffer les algues au ce cas il ya
quelques années on disait que le cloud
enfin le cloud c'est l'ordinateur de
quelqu'un d'autre aujourd'hui faut pas
oublier que la lgo c'est la décision de
quelqu'un d'autre
j'avais fait ya deux ans un peu points
il ya deux ans j'avais fait une des
premières gestion de crise sur accident
provoqué par un véhicule autonome et la
question si tu veux était
une voiture ne ne dise fonctionne pas
elle choisit de percuter en bus d'enfant
plutôt que une navette de business man
noir ou un noir ou en bas où une femme
enceinte ce que tu veux pas ce que tu
veux d'accord donc dans ce cas là on
n'est même pas dans le cadre d'un
dysfonctionnement là c'est quelqu'un qui
a décidé que la voiture en cas de
problème prendra cette décision là les
solutions pour tous à
auditer les choses
sensibiliser les gens au fait que
toute personne 1 de la valeur enfin je
sais pas c'est une éducation et une
culture à faire tu vois et surtout pas
parce que tu trouves que ça en prend le
chemin
[Applaudissements]
enfin on n'est pas les pires le tiens il
ya il ya beaucoup de gens en france qui
réfléchissent et dont on entend la voix
je pense à antonio casilli je pense aux
c'est nul je pense à cardon dominique
cardon en france il ya si tu veux des
gens dont on entend la voix heureusement
et pas seulement des personnes dont je
tairai le nom qui écrivent des tribunaux
c'est un une collection de buzz word et
où chaque mot pourrait éventuellement
faire sens pris individuellement mais la
phrase que d'annoncer nous attend c'est
sûr caméra après je vais me faire
attaquer pour difficile si on dirait qu
on arrive bientôt à la fin
tu vois des choses à rajouter est ce que
tu veux qu'on aborde des choses pour
l'intérêt général ce que tu vois des ce
que tu as un sujet qui tient à coeur
qu'on n'a pas abordé
pourquoi des édité chez larousse
d'ailleurs
pourquoi pas on voit pas parce que déjà
la commander venus deux
c'est une démarche intellectuelle de
leur part oui mais oui les deux actrices
avec qui j'ai travaillé
combien tu as touché
c'est pas de leur fait de talât n'ont
pas tué
je serais toi moi aussi fait cas
d'évasion fiscale non
c'est pas ton copain t'as pas de phobie
administrative
tu demanderais la nationalité française
je ne répondrai pas à cette question
est ce que la france te fait toujours
rêver
pas toujours il ya quand même beaucoup
de sexisme et il ya beaucoup de tu
trouves qu'il du sexisme au chevet à
coeur
comme partout il ya des cons partout
hein parce qu'on est plus tolérant les
hackers
il ya des cons partout enfin il y a des
gens enfin oui après ça mieux autrement
ça dépend ce dépend autant non attends
ça dépend attends ça dépend à force tu
vois d'interagir avec
les gens de se connaître depuis dix ans
tu vas avec avec beaucoup il ya une
régulation qui se fait
un autre jour il ya une nana que je
connais de loin qui se plaignait que
avec son équipe qui constituait de mai
que les mecs se balancent de trucs genre
à mon appli elle est grosse comme
m'habite
voilà est en fait si tu veux jamais
discuté avec quelques copains et tous
leur réaction a été puissant mais y'a
encore des gens pour sortir ce genre de
conneries
ta réaction quoi tu vois et en fait je
me suis du coup de conte et à force au
final de se fréquenter pendant des
années et ces deux sauteurs réguler sur
ce qui est drôle ce qui pastiche science
qui est pénible ce qui menace ça va mais
tous les autres gens qu'on fréquente pas
et qui n'ont pas ces points de
contact avec à dire une partie des gens
un peu plus évoluée
ces gens là en fait ma non pas ses
repères là donc du coup ils vont te
sortir des blagues de merde comme ça à
longueur de journée ils vont rigoler
tiens c'est pour ça que les histoires de
sex-toys
j'arrive à la gérer mais parce que assez
rapidement en fait j'y puise les blagues
surtout que tu es plus marrante
bon allez on three kyats un mot alors
une question d'internet un mot sur musk
face à zuckerberg et compagnie sur la
régulation d'intelligence artificielle
appareils connectés domotique etc qu'est
ce que tu penses d'une intelligence
artificielle qui discute avec une haute
intelligence artificielle et quand cette
intelligence artificielle avec sa copine
elle développe son propre langage et sa
propre son propre chiffre donc à ce que
ça te fait peur pas peur est ce que
c'est normal qu'elles développent toutes
les deux
sénégas coopératif cette histoire en
fait je
j'ai l'impression que c'est surtout
beaucoup de deux d'incompréhension de la
part de journalistes technique qui est
en fait le truc intègre aussi c'est moi
impressions après que deux milliardaires
se bouffe
le cul sur des points de détail
commerciale tu as rien à [__] enfin
c'est pas autant autant jusqu'alors
bergues il dit que se priver de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est une
grosse faute autant musk et est inquiet
est ce que tu peux comprendre son
inquiétude ou pas je le connais parce
qu'elle ait un tu vois j'ai pas bu avec
lui je sais pas moi après enfin en
revient toujours
regarde pas comme ça arrête de balancer
quoi tu vas pas dire là qu'on a bu un
simple c'est bon je les dis
non mais je reviens à notre notre
discussion de tout à l'heure c'est c'est
la décision de quelqu'un d'autre à
partir du moment où il ya un
déséquilibre de pouvoir et des pouvoirs
de qui peut décider pour la majorité on
a un problème que ce soit muscles que
soit juch que soit je ne sais pas qui tu
vois c'est on est déjà quand on est sur
facebook on est les vassaux
et encore
de plus en plus les serres sur le
domaine seigneurial de monsieur
zuckerberg
il faut pas que nos voitures nos frigos
poubelles machin se transforme 1
un territoire seigneuriaux comme ça de
ce genre à la surtout quand ça vient
jusque chez nous dernière question rien
d'autre à aborder
ça va rouler après
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
si tu devais laisser une bouteille à la
mer
impérissable
reste aux jeunes laissent leur un
conseil ce que tu veux
simplement parce que moi j'ai 6 ans dans
ma tête alors jeune plus jeune que moi
ou un peu plus âgés comme le conseil que
tu aurais aimé recevoir
on va dire quand tu avais 15 piges 12
piges mettez les capotes
protégez-vous qua non mais enfin ça
c'est un vrai truc on voit qu'il ya une
recrudescence des maladies sexuellement
transmissibles
du coup et protégez-vous
sans anxiété mais psion sur internet
c'est pareil cas pour m mettez des
capotes enfin faites attention à vous
une tourte et bien les gens tout
simplement un très bon tu sais si je
veux pas rentrer dans un truc
culpabilisant attention au facteur 10 3
m au fond maternaliste montera pas de
photo de toi pour aller sur internet
c'est de notre sens sur un moment donné
où c'est dire aux gens bas si quelqu'un
te fait une place dans le métro c'est
parce qu'il n'avait pas de cas ce que tu
vois c'est ça sert à rien comme conseils
là je veux dire c'est contreproductif il
ne reste pas moins que deux points de
vue c'est qu on va dire très
très professionnelle enfin si on regarde
ça d'un point de vue c'est qu
à partir du moment où une information
que ce soit un texto une photo machin
sors de ton contrôle exclusif et va chez
qui tue la confier à quelqu'un
ça devient une app était quoi
un danger péril menace persistante
d'accord donc la question c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de solution technique à ça
du coup faut vraiment faim faites
attention à qui vous fait confiance et
que le jour où il la confiance est
rompue de toute façon c'est terminé donc
ça il faut le savoir il faut se rendre
compte qu'on est vulnérable et que basse
on peut très bien vivre avec cette
vulnérabilité la condition qu'elles
soient maîtrisés et est connue ils n'ont
pas se retrouver comme des coups
bas ici à rogue autrement encore ta
couverture la tiens c'est
le nôtre mais le
merci d'être venus bah merci pour les
puits
au plaisir
clap de fin
[Musique]